[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic
l'électrodynamique quantique lorsque
deux électrons se rapproche il se
repoussent ceci explique qu'on ne
traverse pas une chaise lorsqu'on
s'assoit que l'on peut exercer une force
sur un objet que l'air exercent des
frottements sur une plume à part la
gravité et la radioactivité à l'échelle
du noyau des atomes presque tous les
phénomènes de l'univers s'explique par
la façon dont se comportent les
électrons a priori on serait tenté de
décrire cette répulsion par une force la
force électromagnétique
mais les électrons ne sont pas des
petites billes qui obéirait à la
mécanique classique
il s'agit d'objets et cantiques des
particules et pour décrire leurs
interactions il est nécessaire de
concilier électromagnétisme et physique
quantique à cette fin au milieu du xxème
siècle fut développé le modèle le plus
précis jamais créés dans l'histoire de
la physique
un modèle élégant qui permet d'utiliser
de simples diagramme pour calculer avec
une précision stupéfiante les phénomènes
les plus fondamentaux de la physique
celle l'électrodynamique quantique
l'électrodynamique quantique s'inscrit
dans le cadre de la théorie quantique
des champs on considère notre univers
comme une sorte de boîte l'espace-temps
qui renferme deux chants des sortes de
fluides constituée d'objets
mathématiques le champ des électrons et
le champ électromagnétique au sein de
ses champs se déplacent des petits
paquets d'énergie qui peuvent apparaître
et disparaître ce qu'on appelle des
particules les électrons par exemple
sont des perturbations qui se propage
comme des ondes à l'intérieur du champ
des électrons le champ électromagnétique
contient lui aussi des perturbations des
quantas d'énergie qui peuvent apparaître
ou disparaître
on les appelle photons le champ des
électrons et celui des photons sont de
nature différente
les objets mathématiques qui les
composent ne sont pas du même type le
champ des électrons en particulier est
constitué de spinner des objets plutôt
abstrait que l'on décrit par des nombres
complexes
pour simplifier on peut imaginer un
nombre complexe comme ayant une taille
ainsi qu'une couleur sa phase
[Musique]
lorsqu'un électrons se propage dans le
champ la phase des nombres complexes
tourner au cours du temps c'est ce qu'on
appelle la charge électrique
les électrons ont une charge électrique
qui correspond au fait que leur phase
tourner lorsqu'il avance vers le futur
[Musique]
mise à part les électrons ce même champ
peut également contenir des
perturbations dont la phase tourner dans
l'autre sens en quelque sorte on
pourrait dire qu'il s'agit d'un électron
mais qui se déplacerait en sens inverse
vers le passé de notre point de vue la
phase de cette particule semble tourner
en sens inverse
on perçoit une charge électrique opposé
c'est ce qu'on appelle un anti électrons
un positon d'autre part le champ des
photons et quant à lui formé de vecteurs
que l'on exprime à partir de nombres
réels
il s'agit simplement de nombres
ordinaires qui n'ont pas de phases
si bien que les photons n'ont pas de
charge électrique
pour comprendre comment interagissent
les électrons imaginons qu'on en place
deux au départ de notre champ quantique
afin de représenter schématiquement le
contenu de l'univers
il est pratique de symboliser le
mouvement des particules par des lignes
une ligne avec une flèche vers le futur
pour symboliser un électron avec une
flèche vers le passé dans l'autre sens
pour symboliser un positon et une ligne
qui ondule pour symboliser un photon
pour décrire la façon dont évoluent les
particules l'électrodynamique quantique
autorise nos deux champs à interagir à
l'aide de points d'interaction un point
d'interaction fait intervenir un photon
et deux particules de type électrons il
peut s'agir d'électrons ou de positons
en fonction de leur orientation par
rapport au temps un tel point
d'interaction peut symboliser un
électron qui émettent un photon un
électron qui absorbent un photon un
positon qui émettent un photon ou
absorbent un photon ou encore un
électron et un positon kisan il en un
photon ou un photon qui se convertit en
une paire électron positron
toutes ces interactions sont permises à
condition que pour chaque point
d'interaction le mouvement global des
particules dans l'espace et dans le
temps
avant et après l'interaction reste le
même
la charge électrique doit également être
conservée c'est à dire que chaque
interaction a nécessairement une flèche
qui entrent et l'autre qui ressort en
autorisant nos deux électrons à
interagir avec ce genre de liaison on
peut alors imaginer tout un tas de
scénarios différents
dans le scénario le plus simple les deux
électrons continue en ligne droite à
vitesse constante
dans un autre scénario plus intéressant
les deux électrons s'échange d'un photon
qui va servir d'intermédiaire en
communiquant une partie du mouvement du
premier électrons au second électrons il
est important de noter que les
particules se comportent comme des ondes
et peuvent donc être échangé dans un
sens même si elle transmet un mouvement
qui est orientée différemment
de cette façon dans certains scénarios
les changes va rapprocher les deux
électrons
et dans d'autres scénarios les changes
vallée éloignée
[Musique]
on peut alors imaginer des scénarios
plus complexes qui font intervenir
davantage de points d'interaction les
électrons peuvent s'échanger plusieurs
fautes on a différents endroits et à
différents instants parfois les photons
se convertissent tempère électron
positron kisan il pour reformer un
photon c'est ce qu'on appelle une boucle
un électron peut également émettre puis
réabsorber un photon a priori tant que
le mouvement global et la charge
électrique sont conservés
tous les scénarios imaginables une
infinité de possibilités plus ou moins
complexes sont susceptibles de se
produire
et si l'on stoppe l'évolution du champ
après un certain temps et que l'on
regarde l'issue de chaque scénario on
retrouve parfois nos deux électrons et
parfois davantage de particules
certaines étant apparues entre l'instant
initial et l'instant final chacun de ces
scénarios qui part d'une situation
initiale pour atteindre une situation
final est ce qu'on appelle un diagramme
de feynman
les diagrammes de feynman retranscrivent
symboliquement les différentes
évolutions possibles de nos champs
quantique à partir d'une même situation
initiale
mis à part les particules initial et
final qui sont des particules réel que
l'on peut détecter les particules qui
agissent comme des intermédiaires à
l'intérieur de ces diagrammes sont dites
virtuel ce sont des particules que l'on
ne détecte pas et elles peuvent
présenter des caractéristiques assez
étrange
elles ne servent que d'intermédiaire
pour décrire comment interagissent à
distance nos deux électrons
mathématiquement chaque scénario chaque
diagramme de feynman correspondent à une
équation bien rigoureuse et les
particules virtuelles ne sont qu'une
façon d'interpréter intuitivement
certains intermédiaires de calcul qui
apparaissent dans ces équations
ceci dit bien qu'elle ne soit que des
intermédiaires issus de notre modèle
mathématique il est essentiel de
considérer ces particules virtuelles car
ce sont elles qui permettent de prendre
en compte les interactions entre les
chants et donc d'expliquer le
comportement des électrons résumons ce
dont on dispose jusqu'ici ont décrite un
espace-temps qui contient deux champs
celui des électrons et celui des photons
à partir d'une situation initiale avec
deux électrons on s'intéresse à tous les
scénarios d'évolution possible en
autorisant des interactions qui relie
chacune un photon et deux particules de
type électron ou positon ainsi on peut
dresser un catalogue une liste de tous
les diagrammes possible il en existe une
infinité
certains sont simples contiennent peu
d'interactions d'autres sont plus
complexes
ils font intervenir beaucoup
d'interactions
mais ceci ne nous avance pas trop si
l'on souhaite prédire le comportement
réel des électrons on voudrait savoir
lequel de ces scénarios se produit
véritablement si on réalise l'expérience
est ce ce scénario ou alors cette autre
scénario qui va réellement se produire
la réponse à cette question est subtil
et peut paraître contre intuitive mais
il s'agit là précisément de ce qui fait
toute la puissance de la théorie
quantique notre univers n'évolue pas
selon un seul de ces scénarios il évolue
en même temps selon tous les scénarios
possibles
d'une certaine façon à partir d'une même
situation initiale toutes les
possibilités d'évolution se produisent
en même temps en parallèle dans une
superposition de tous les scénarios
imaginables pour décrire le comportement
des électrons il est nécessaire de
prendre en compte tous les diagrammes de
feynman
en électro dynamique quantique chaque
diagramme se voit associé une équation
qui lui correspond et qui va permettre
de calculer un nombre pour chaque
scénario une amplitude
on peut imaginer les diagrammes comme
des calques et leur amplitude comme une
sorte d'opacité qui parfois s'ajoutent
de façon constructive et parfois de
façon non destructive les différents
scénarios ont chacun des amplitudes
différentes et dans le cadre des calculs
on peut la plupart du temps négliger les
scénarios les plus complexes ne
considérer que les quelques premiers
diagramme les plus simples et quand même
obtenir des résultats raisonnablement
précis c'est en effectuant la somme de
tous ces scénarios avec leurs
différentes amplitudes un peu comme si
l'on superpose est d kalck plus ou moins
opaque que l'on obtient l'évolution
réelle du système physique lorsqu'on
effectue l'expérience dans le monde réel
si on lance deux électrons et qu'on les
observe un peu plus tard les amplitudes
de chaque diagramme vont nous permettre
de calculer la probabilité pour que l'on
observe telle ou telle issue à la sortie
de notre expérience et en particulier
l'issue la plus probable est que l'on
observe nos deux électrons avec des
mouvements légèrement différent ils se
sont repoussés
d'une certaine façon les diagrammes de
feynman ne sont pas ton des
représentations de phénomènes réels que
des outils de calcul très puissant pour
prédire la probabilité d'observer telle
ou telle issue enfin d'expérience on a
davantage de chances de retrouver nos
deux électrons avec des mouvements vers
l'extérieur les sus la plus probable est
qu'ils se repoussent grâce aux échanges
de particules virtuelles à notre échelle
on a l'impression que les deux électrons
subissent une force en continu alors que
fondamentalement à l'échelle quantique
cette force n'est que la synthèse
probabiliste de tous les scénarios
d'interactions possibles dans lesquelles
les électrons s'échange une partie de
leur mouvement par l'intermédiaire de
particules virtuelles
[Musique]
non
pour conclure l'électrodynamique
quantique est une théorie complexe mais
qui permet de prédire de façon
stupéfiante la façon dont ils
interagissent les électrons les positons
et les photons en synthétisant tous les
scénarios possibles avec leurs
différentes amplitudes cette théorie
permet d'expliquer et de prédire à
l'échelle fondamentale toutes les lois
de l'optique
le comportement de la lumière
lorsqu'elle interagit avec un matériau
les équations de maxwell qui régissent
les champs électriques et magnétiques et
les interactions entre les électrons
dont découlent presque tous les
phénomènes de force à notre échelle
historiquement ce modèle fut le premier
grand succès de la théorie quantique des
champs en décrivant la matière par des
chants quantique les interactions par
des particules virtuelles et en
proposant une méthode de calcul très
élégante à base de diagrammes et
d'amplitude l'électrodynamique quantique
a permis notamment de prédire avec une
précision jamais égalée auparavant la
façon dont un électron réagi dans un
champ magnétique par l'intermédiaire de
photons virtuel le champ magnétique fait
tourner le spin de l'électron sur lui
même et ce mouvement de pré session est
parfaitement prédit par
l'électrodynamique quantique à près de
dix chiffres après la virgule
à ce jour il s'agit tout théorique ont
fondu de la prédiction expérimental la
mieux vérifier dans l'histoire de la
physique
c'est le moment magnétique anomales de
l'électron
[Musique]
pour en savoir plus sur les diagrammes
de feynman rendez vous sur la chaîne
sciences i avec rigueur
[Musique]